الأمين العام
للأمم المتحدة المحترم أنطونيو
غوتيرز، أطلب منكم أن
تفعلوا شيئًا الآن، وأحثكم
الليلة على إنشاء حملة جسر جوي
باستخدام طائرات شحن بيضاء تابعة للأمم المتحدة للسفر
إلى غزة بالمياه
والغذاء وكل ما هو مطلوب، ونحن نعرف
ما هو مطلوب على
الفور.  أن يأتي لمساعدة
1.5 مليون فلسطيني نازح داخليًا
في غازا، وهم
الآن عطشى حتى الموت، ويموتون جوعًا،
والفرسان
يزداد برودة في غزة، وأغلبية
النازحين داخليًا هم من
الأطفال، كما
يدعي جيش الاحتلال الإسرائيلي.  كن آمنًا في الجنوب
ليس آمنًا، لقد قُتل 40% من القتلى
في
الجنوب، وأحثكم على جلب الإمدادات، وإنشاء
حملة جسر جوي، وتجرؤ على تحدي
الحصار الوحشي والقتل الذي يتعرض له
الشعب الفلسطيني في غزة، هذا وضع حرج في الوقت الحالي.
عليك أن تتحرك الآن، وإذا
سمحت لإسرائيل بمواصلة المجاعة وقتل
الشعب الفلسطيني في غزة من خلال المجاعة
والمياه والغذاء فإنك ستكون
متواطئا.